what have you been up to
um I got a new pc nice yeah because your
physique is breaking for some reason so
I okay this is my I gotta I I don't
reached out to uh sponsor PC specialist
we work with a lot I was kind of like
hey my stream keeps crashing uh it I
think it's because I had like a graphics
card that was bad because I I had an old
PC and I got a new pc because I want to
build a new one because it kept crashing
right and I thought okay well I'm gonna
change everything except the graphics
card and I got the new pc and I built it
and I had problems starting that one
right it went all wrong I had the wrong
I had the wrong Ram it was man it was a
whole thing I got it working I have the
same issue it would just crash and it
would like all what would happen is it's
like blue screen or what no no I I would
um wouldn't even do that
I'll be streaming
all the screens go black
all right and then it will come back the
stream will be ended because the stream
is rendered through the graphics card
yeah it'll stop streaming stop every
application and it'll also act up weird
if I try to restart the stream it'll
kind of struggle with games so I kind of
just have to restart my PC right and it
would just keep doing this whenever I
played a game that's pretty intense and
I was like [__] this man I I it happened
once or twice I was like that's it I'm
done I'm like I'm just gonna get one
that is completely brand new has nothing
to do with me I'm not touching it I
don't have anything because clearly I'm
a [__] curse so I got a new pc and I
started setting it up you know how it is
it's kind of exciting when you get a new
pc and you say like I am going to make
sure the file management is clean as
[__] this time and in a month it's not
going to be clear yeah yes but you're
like you're in your head you're like
committed to it and it's kind of
exciting because you kind of get
everything fresh everything's super fast
it all works yeah for sure set it all up
everything's fine
three days later uh I I shut down the PC
and it had an update but I was like I'm
pretty sure it did the updates so I just
shut it down I went to bed I came back
in the morning and it was on the boot
screen and I was like what the [__] I
shut it down okay and it was just stuck
on it just wouldn't move oh no and I was
like what I'm like oh man oh man so I
try everything that I know yeah I try to
fix it in every single way and I'm just
having no luck and but I know because
it's it's booting and I can get to all
the windows repair stuff I'm like okay
maybe worst case scenario I think I just
have to reinstall Windows but I don't
want to do that because I've already set
everything up and I'm just like oh man
so I contact them I'm like hey guys the
PC is great it's fine it's awesome
beautiful account management it's
beautiful 490 is so good yeah 490
beautiful it's absolute monster if
you'll run TFT amazing
um and um
that's why I asked I'm like hey it's
it's not working it's really expensive
and dude can you help me figure it out
and stuff and so like I got on call with
a a very nice British man uh and he
would walk me through all the stuff and
he was like yep it looks like got to
reinstall Windows I was like [__] and he
was like yeah but he's like it's so it's
fine that's good that's the best thing
I'm like why is it the best he's like
well because yeah if there's anything
else it means it's all [__] yeah it's
like okay
so I had to reinstall windows again do
that so for the last like three days
I've just been reinstalling everything
again and yeah dude it's so finicky
because like man if it was just
reinstalling software it wouldn't be a
bad idea but it's like I gotta reset up
all my stream stuff and it takes so long
yeah yeah for sure and there's always
something you're missing yep and it's
always like and then you're like doing
something and you're like [__] I didn't
install that I gotta do that again and
it just takes like hours like I don't
want to spend six hours doing this
especially not when I've already done it
it's a it's funny you say that you have
like a PC codes because the PC you built
for me like three four years ago I
haven't had a single problem with yeah
you know you know Joey what if what have
you been using that PC for though you
know I feel like I am I am I am burning
myself I regularly like push my PC like
fully but I still think it's breaking
way more than it even should if I'm
doing yeah yeah yeah yeah like if you
were playing like a triple A game A Lot
your graphics card is probably being
fully used oh yeah for sure so I I don't
understand it shouldn't be doing this
that's why I'm a console game yeah
console Gamers don't have to worry about
your Nintendo just plug and play baby
let's go well it's because I'm a lot of
the time I'm streaming and so you're
streaming and then you're running the
game and the stream is running off the
graphics card but then I also like to
record locally yes uh just because
stream when you when you upload a stream
to Twitch yeah uh they absolutely murder
the quality yeah like it's even worse
than YouTube like it's so bad yeah
because you can only do six megabytes
per second which is like it looks fine
in 1080 people you can't upload anything
higher like at all and
um it'd be nice because I'd like to
um but it just means that certain games
look like ass like I don't know if
you've ever watched a stream of like
vampire survivors oh yeah yeah where it
just goes like it's just like pixels
yeah you're like oh there are four
pixels on the screen this is like
because the twitch compression just just
like it just cannot handle certain
things on yeah there's a lot of stuff on
screen I can't do it I I always locally
save my streams as well so yes I locally
save it because if I want to make a
YouTube video out of it which I do
there's like a ton of benefits one being
it looks way better and you can record a
much higher bit rate yeah uh you can
also record a different resolution which
I'm going to do now I can record it in
2K instead of 1080p so I can the videos
will just look better yeah the reason
why you like I can't attended to be fine
yeah but it's like future proofing like
it used to be that like 1080p was always
fine but now if you play a 1080p video
on a TV it looks like a ass yeah so it's
like okay because everyone has a 4K TV
that's like 60 inches right so I'm just
kind of future proofing it also I like
to separate all the audio channels this
is so nerdy I know I'm sorry but like
just so that if moving wants to in post
he can edit all the audio levels like if
the game's too loud yeah yeah yeah it's
just like a whole thing
I don't know 1080p to 4K
can't I kind of get it kind of don't on
a TV you notice the difference because
because maybe not we noticed it on your
phone with a movie you won't notice
right because DVDs they're like expertly
like uh made and you don't get this dog
[__] compression that YouTube does yeah
like our videos in 4k don't look like 4K
because YouTube compresses the [__] out
of them yeah yeah but there's always
going to be compression online yeah I
know I know I know but like if you
watched a movie on a stream yeah it's
it's so like what are you trying to do
is like if you upload like a higher
quality video to YouTube it'll compress
it like like a stop down right so what
you're trying to do is is by doing a
higher quality is like you're trying to
get ahead of like YouTube compression so
the 1080p doesn't look like 720 so that
like you know so that when you upload
something in 2K it'll look much better
in 1080P when someone watches it right
yeah I guess because like for me I've
tested around with this before and I've
noticed even if I have a 1080p video
because most anime are in 1080P that's
why yeah
um so that's fine for you that makes
like no difference yeah it doesn't
really make as big of a difference for
anime as I I feel for like other film
yeah like live action stuff live action
it's like yeah it's night and day yeah
yeah
um and I've tested it and I've like
tested
uploading 4K rendered videos for a 1080p
video uh which should should just make
no difference because all you're doing
is upscaling the pixels and it looks
better because
if you upload in 4k YouTube Just Go
YouTube yeah you know because then
people who can watch it in 4k be able to
watch it and basically a less compressed
version of 1080p yeah uh also for like
if you're ever doing anything with like
actual cameras the reason why you want
higher high resolution which is super
useful is you can punch in and it
doesn't look like [__] yeah digital you
can zoom you can like yeah zoom in the
frame a lot yeah
um that's very useful like sometimes if
you ever like you know people's like oh
8K camera why the [__] would you ever
need that it's like the one benefit is
that like let's say if uh me and Joey
are in the same frame we're next to each
other and it's 8K you could zoom in on
me and it would still look like 2K yeah
you know what I mean and it wouldn't
look like Blurry as [__] yeah
um sorry this is like whole technical
stuff but it's like so not interesting
but it's just like and I'm sure there's
some camera experts who can you're like
no that's not how it works but it's like
get him okay that's how it feels as a
tech nerd do you think we'll need more
than 4K eventually do you think we'll
get up to like you know 16k 32k TVs and
stuff like that well I don't I don't
think it'll I mean they'll certainly be
available because but I don't know
because I remember back in the day
people said that about 1080p that's what
I'm saying yeah like back in the day
like early YouTube when like the most
you could go was like 7 20 or even like
480. we were like oh 720 is is wow
that's HD that's that looks good but now
we're like oh I don't know I certainly
think the cameras uh will definitely
keep getting higher resolution just
because it's more useful again for
editing yeah and being able to
manipulate them yeah I'm not talking
about like the editing thing um I'm
talking about me losing my eyes I mean
they'll probably get there but it
probably will be like such such
diminishing returns yeah especially 4K
to 8K is like I'm I'm dude it's barely
anything because like okay for me like I
see people freaking out over like you
know 4K 4K does look [__] good like
straight up it does look really good
like to me okay with like like my
opinion right like I'd be I'd be blind
to say that it doesn't look better 4K
does like object objectively look better
yes
um but like in terms of like how much it
makes a difference to like whatever like
my immersion or something like that it's
just it it doesn't like the the amount
the amount of like new pixels and the
amount of resolution you're adding just
doesn't feel as different to when 1080p
was just introduced versus like 360
people yeah and it just feels like the
the returns are getting more diminishing
the like well yeah right now it's way
more about you know how was it filmed
and how is it uh how are the colors yeah
I was about to say like you know it's
it's way more about lighting and colors
now that's why there's a giant focus on
HDR oh no yeah I totally agree where I
think like from from my own personal
life perspective if something is lit and
filmed correctly in 1080P
way more important than just having like
a 4K resolution yeah
um obviously if you can combine both
then [__] [__] incredible yeah but
I feel like this
focus on just having something that's
like higher resolution 4K it was like to
me it doesn't make that much of a
difference yeah and uh it's crazy how
much lighting is everything yeah right
it's really like insane yeah like
because you know when you're starting on
YouTube you're like I'm gonna get a
little Sony little camera just a little
and then you're like why does it look
like ass yeah like why does every other
YouTubers videos look so good and mine
looks so dogs oh it's because I'm using
a tiny [__] desk lamp it's because I
have no light I'm also the sun is behind
me and uh I have a flickering light in
the back you're just like oh yeah yeah
oh this [__] sucks you're like I have
to make the whole room well balanced and
I have to make sure I'm lit and then the
background's lit differently otherwise
it just looks like found footage yeah
because like my you know like my stream
setup is like I have two lights for my
face yeah and then the the rest of the
room is lit differently and it's like it
looks it's insane how different it looks
like if I turn the lights off I never
showed you with the lights on you'd
think oh it's not that bad I turn them
on you're like oh whoa It's like a lot
different oh yeah for sure it's it's
yeah it's it's uh it's annoying because
you're like as a YouTuber you want to
always improve your videos and you want
to well I express it for a good video I
guess a good YouTuber
listen if you if you're a professional
anything or you'd claim to be you should
be always looking how to get better at
it right of course you know like [__]
uh Van Gogh didn't paint one picture
he's like I'm done boys that's it no
more I'm gonna that's it I've made it
you know like you always want to improve
right yes if you're passionate about it
absolutely and the thing that sucks
about being a YouTuber is that like
you're like okay I want to upgrade my
audio and you're like holy [__] this is
complicated how the F to get like 10
better audio I have to learn like a
hundred percent more worth of like
information yeah I'm saying like 10
times the price as well yeah and pay
like quadruple the price yeah especially
with camera gear oh my God cameras and
lighting it it's it's insane how
exponentially it goes up for like again
diminishing returns yeah yeah like you
can look like Marcus Brownlee but do you
have the money of Marcus Bradley and
more importantly do you have somebody
who knows how to then use that stuff yes
you can buy these like Cinema RED
cameras but if you don't got a good
lighting guy and a good and a good uh
like person who knows how to do all the
coloring in the software or you're
[__] yeah for sure which I don't
yeah which is why it's it's weird seeing
if like just like my philosophy which is
isn't always about making things let's
say look the most highest resolution and
stuff like that I'm more I'm like way
more focused on like writing and like
just editing because I mean I think
because you're so focused on anime yeah
and you don't show your face in all your
videos like it doesn't matter like it's
kind of like it's kind of like the uh
you know Nintendo and Microsoft versus
like the uh sorry the Nintendo versus
the Microsoft and Sony group you know
[__] you got like the PS5 and the
Xbox series X or whatever that's just
like power more power more pixels are
the Nintendo's like I'm gonna do weirdo
[__] let's uh but it's like it's like
when you have those like in my mind I
see it as like let's say you have a
YouTube Vlog yeah and it's from like a
smaller Channel and they've just started
it's like it's goddamn like the camera
work everything's just [__] awful no
one has a certain charm towards that
there's a bit of a charm but also if you
just straight up can't see what they're
trying to film you're like great
you just wasted like this entire point
like I can't see anything and that's all
I'm gonna be opening up Pokemon cards
today in a dark room yeah uh here's my
hat yeah
I don't know
there's a charm I don't think I don't
think I can't doesn't get you to like
yeah I don't think a content creator can
always remain that kind of level but
like I would something about having
seeing like a new YouTuber or something
and them having like the shittiest
[__] mic that piece oh yeah every
five seconds
something about that I'm just like you
know what maybe this is Peak YouTube I
don't know anymore you know this is yeah
I think I think an important part of
being a YouTuber especially one that
does well is that you you make you
upload your video and you're like that's
good and then you watch another person's
video like
way better than what I just uploaded
yeah and then you're like how did they
do that and you start just figuring it
out